bonjour ou la taz merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui sur rt france
on l'a vu à emmen emmanuel macron et au
liban depuis hier quels sont les enjeux
de cette deuxième visite le concernant
ou concernant le peuple libanais parce
que je suis maintenant avant qu'il
n'arrive à beyrouth avait déjà à un
mouvement populaire énorme contre contre
la nomination du premier ministre
n'avons rien contre
le premier mise en question le connais
pas assez mais contre la classe
politique qui l'a nommé monsieur m'a
cran à a mis là haut la barre très très
haut lors de sa première visite
nous étions très heureux de voir que la
france s'est mise encore une fois à côté
du peuple libanais des demandes du
peuple libanais qui ne demandent rien
que qu'à se débarrasser de cette classe
politique mafieuse et terroristes qui
nous gouverne depuis 40 ans et on on
pensait que la france allait mettre le
allait nous aider à mettre la pression
pour que les symboles de cette classe
politique finalement lâche le morceau et
quittent leur poste moins que cette
année est très très déçus très déçus de
monsieur marcoing et de sa visite à
beyrouth
quel rôle pour justement jouer la france
où quel rôle les libanais mon vrai que
la france joue dans cette transition
politique
il ya une énorme pression mondiale sur
cette classe politique que ce soit à
travers les sanctions prochaine qui vont
qui vise les plus hauts responsables
d'une classe politique qui a volé les
caisses du libanais
on espérait bien que la france va aussi
mettre la pression dans le même sens
c'est ou bien les sanctions ou bien
qu'ils débarrassent quoi vous nous
n'accepterons pas un 1er mai même s'il
est bien même si c'est un type bien je
ne le juge pas je ne le connais pas mais
c'est cette classe politique qui ramène
des premiers mise pour se protéger parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils sont qui sont
criminels qu'ils ont causé une énorme
catastrophe à beyrouth
si vous voulez qu'on parle de la crise
économique et financière causée par eux
les milliards de dollars qu'ils ont volé
dans les caisses du libanais nous sommes
aujourd'hui un peuple appauvri un an un
peuple meurtri
nous ne pouvons plus vivre dans un pays
où il ya un terroriste qui s'appelle
l'angola qui qui fait à sa guise qui
nous tiennent qui nous tient otage de sa
politique iranienne au liban
c'est tout un système monsieur qui doit
tomber vous viviez vous lisiez je me
permets de vous coupent et roulent à taj
à l'instant c'est tout un peuple qui n'a
plus confiance en sa politique en tout
cas en séance et gouvernement qu'est ce
qui attend le peuple que veut exactement
le peuple dans l'est dans les jours qui
vont qui vont suivre
ben on espère et on travaille pour
mettre la pression interne et
internationale pour que tout ce beau
monde dégage
il faut qu'il dégage il ya le président
du parlement il doit dégager
parce que il détient une force énorme
que ça soit une paramilitaires ou
apolitiques et j'espère bien que le
président on va comprendre que il pourra
rien faire il pourra rien faire pour que
les gens pour calmer la situation au
liban
ils sont tous coupables tous ensemble
c'est comme des familles de la mafia qui
quand ils sont d'accord ils sont
d'accord pour nous voler davantage
et quand ils sont
quand ils sont plus en bons termes c'est
la catastrophe
c'est la guerre civile merci beaucoup
roulent à table d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui sur rt frange rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique merci
beaucoup activistes passent en ce moment
merci